[Music]
good night mabel
good night dipper
falls it is good to be back
[Music]
hello internet welcome tiffy wreath
destroying your favorite show's perfect
endings one
by one and today is going to be no
exception hardly because gravity falls
is a show that i never
want to end but mostly because when you
look at how this show
actually ended the evidence points to
there being much more to this story than
we saw play out on
screen now the show's final trilogy of
episodes at first glance does pretty
much everything that a great serious
finale is supposed to
family grudges are forgiven loved ones
are saved and evil is finally defeated
but
re-watching the finale there was one
thing that just didn't quite
sit right with me in the finale bill
cipher
evil dorito of gravity falls travels to
our world to create the apocalypse he
calls
weirdmageddon however once here on earth
he realizes that he's trapped in gravity
falls due to the town's
natural law of weirdness magnetism in
order to escape and spread his reign of
weirdness to the rest of the world bill
has to get inside the mind of
one man ford pines resident genius
paranormal investigator and great uncle
to our heroes dipper and mabel
however this requires that bill make a
deal with ford by
shaking his hand to defeat bill once and
for all
ford and his twin brother stanley switch
clothes to trick bill into making the
deal with the much less able-minded stan
with the deal made and bill now trapped
inside stan's head
ford uses a gun that can erase memories
on stanley
wiping out everything in his mind
including bill
cipher himself stan in a moment of pure
heroism makes the ultimate sacrifice
losing himself losing his identity and
losing
all memories of the loved ones he left
behind
for about three minutes yeah it's not
all that much of a sacrifice as it turns
out as stan's memories come back in less
time than it takes to mix up a blender
full of mabel juice so what's going on
here well
thankfully journal number three gives us
a little more context on how
all this happened quote it turns out
that the memory raise effects can be
undone through exposure to important
images and
people from your past the reason stan
recovered so much faster is that we
began recovery while the erasure was
still
fresh less than an hour after contact
end quote but at this point you've
probably figured out where i'm going
with all this
if all of grunkle stan's memories
weren't permanently wiped out
would that also mean that bill cipher
wasn't permanently wiped out
it's a question that fans have been
asking for the past two years
is bill cipher the main antagonist of
gravity falls
really dead and i am here today to tell
you
no bill cipher is alive and well
and living in paris with jacques brell
sorry sorry never mind that last bit
it's a really obscure musical theater
reference that
no one and i mean no one will get in all
seriousness though looking at all the
evidence from the end of the show as
well as content that's been released
after the series
ended points to bill cipher still
kicking around and not
just kicking around what we on earth
today will not only change your thoughts
about the end of the series but also
everything you thought you knew about
one of your favorite characters
intrigued excellent grappling hook away
first we can absolutely prove that bill
isn't dead
during the finale when bill was trapped
inside stan's mind bill decides to make
these strange
noises
these are his last words of the series
so you'd think he would have chosen his
words a little more carefully or
you know just chosen words but here's
the thing
he actually did choose those words very
specifically
the only reason why it sounds like
gibberish to us is because he's talking
backwards just reverse the clip and you
get this
ancient power that i may return okay
that makes it pretty clear that he ain't
planning on leaving this mortal coil
anytime soon but what's all this about
an axolotl well it turns out that the
answer is given to us in a book
titled dipper and mabel and the curse of
the time pirates treasure
now this book was confirmed to be
non-canon except
alex hirsch the creator of the show
tweeted that it does contain
one enormous canon secret so in the book
dipper and mabel end up face to face
with this all-powerful cosmic axolotl
and are each granted one question
dipper asks the very responsible and
very logical question of
what do you know about bill cipher to
which the axolotl replies
quote 60 degrees that come in threes
watches from within birch trees saw his
own dimension
burn misses home and can't return
says he's happy he's a liar blames arson
for the fire
if he wants to shirk the blame he'll
have to invoke my name
one way to absolve his crime a different
form
a different time end quote gotta love
those classic rhyming couplets now look
at those last few lines
invoke my name to absolve the crimes as
a different form in a different time
yeah this is pretty obvious why bill was
chanting in reverse right before he was
literally brainwashed away
and presumably the axolotl granted his
wish preserving him
in a different form and a different time
that's a pretty strong case for bill
still being alive but if that's truly
the case then that begs the question of
what new form could he possibly be in
well why not the form that he was
already trapped in
grunkle stan and that isn't just
speculation most of the post-show
content that's come out
and believe me there's been a lot for a
show that's been gone for two years has
signaled pretty heavily that bill cipher
continues to exist
within stan's mind case in point the
cipher statue hunt
shortly after gravity falls ended alex
hirsch made it very clear that there was
a real-life bill cipher statue hidden
somewhere in the u.s and that in order
to find it fans would have to solve
a worldwide treasure hunt and while that
is absolutely
cool in and of itself the most
interesting part of this whole thing was
that it appeared to be led by grunkle
stan
one of the very first clues to the hunt
was a phone number when you called it
you would be greeted by this answering
machine message
[Applause]
[Music]
immediately you can recognize stan's
voice but something's a bit off
it's in reverse now this definitely
could just be some attempt to make the
quest
slightly harder but it's worth noting
that every time a character has ever
spoken in reverse during the series
it was because of bill in the episode
dreamscapers gideon speaks in reverse
after reading a chant that summons bill
stemsbro
in a tale of two stans ford speaks
backwards after falling into a
dimensional portal and seeing bill
not to mention that every single opening
theme
ends with whispers in reverse before
we're greeted with a flash of the cipher
wheel
every time someone speaks in reverse on
the show it seems to be an association
with bill cipher
so the fact that we catch stan pine
speaking in reverse over the phone is
already incredibly suspicious but the
evidence doesn't just end there
all objects found throughout this
treasure hunt tend to be related to
either bill or grunkle stan
there were stan bucks a jigsaw puzzle of
bill cipher a golden stan head and a few
other recordings of stan giving out
clues it was always these two characters
that the cipher hunt kept coming back to
an odd choice when considering that
there were so many other characters that
fans would have loved to hear from you
know
like the heroes of the show dipper and
mabel or soos
or wendy or literally anyone else
associated in this series it's
almost as if the creators were hinting
towards a connection between
bill and stan eventually the fans found
the bill cipher statue and beside it was
a chest
filled with some pretty interesting
things there was a journal 3 book that
had a drawing of stan
ford and seuss but if you hover a black
light on this page you'll find bill
cipher drawn in with invisible ink
directly next to stan's head
once again indicating that he's alive
and well and suspiciously close to
grunkle stan
but there was something else in there
that definitely caught my attention when
i was researching this theory
in the chest there was a usb drive of
grunkle stan
singing we'll meet again by verilyn
we'll
meet again don't know
where don't know when
it's an important song choice to make
note of since it's the exact
same song that bill cipher sang to ford
pines in the gravity falls finale
in this show yeah right stan goes on to
congratulate you on finding
his statue hey guys congratulations
on finding my the mysterious treasure of
the
statue in the forest a very interesting
choice of words to be sure
then shortly after he recommends that
you shake the statue's hand
again shake his hand that's kind of like
a prize we've already gone over how bill
cipher is notorious for making deals
that require
shaking his hand and stan knows this as
much as anyone else so why would he be
encouraging us to shake bill cipher's
hand as if that's some sort of prize
unless of course this isn't stanley
talking it's
bill bill talking through stanley
encouraging people to shake his statue's
hand in the real world potentially as a
means of trying to escape from the body
he's already trapped in
trying to make a deal through the statue
seem like too much of a stretch
honestly i thought so too at first but
we already know that bill can mimic
someone else's voice when he's in their
body because we've seen the exact same
thing
happen before on the show specifically
when he was controlling blendin blandin
the time traveling agent in the episode
mabel and dipper vs the future
so it's definitely plausible that the
person we're listening to isn't stanley
at all
but i know i know there's still one big
problem that i'm sure a lot of you will
be asking in the comments
if bill is still alive and is somehow
controlling stanley then why in the
finale
aren't his eyes yellow with an elongated
pupil the signature look of someone
who's under bill cipher's control
well it's because bill only controls
stan
when he sleeps now before you run down
to the comments to tell me that that's a
huge leap in logic hear me out here it
is canonically
something bill has done in the past
specifically with stan's brother
ford in the official journal 3 book ford
describes a deal that he made with bill
30 years before the events of the show a
deal where he let bill
enter his mind and control his body but
during the terms of the deal bill could
only control stanford's body
when he was sleeping page 118 of the
journal
quote i awoke this morning to find that
my muse was true to his word there in my
notebook were six hours worth of
beautifully written calculations
perfectly sufficient to keep me on
schedule
end quote what starts as a mutually
beneficial relationship though
quickly deteriorates as ford starts to
fear bill's influence and actively tries
to stay awake for fear that bill will
continue taking control of his body
again when he falls asleep
page 142 quote again i fell asleep on my
cot
only to awake sitting at my desk staring
at the strange symbols inscribed below
he is taking
advantage while i sleep end quote
this tells us that it is very possible
bill is only controlling stan
at night notice how in the cipher hunt
we never actually see stan's face
only a bunch of pre-recorded audio files
audio files that could have been
set up in the middle of the night so
there you have it a theory on bill
cipher being alive and trapped inside
stanley's mind i think there's a lot of
evidence for it but you know while i was
researching this theory it struck me
it's pretty crazy how close these two
characters are with each other it's
almost as if they've been connected on a
deeper level since the very beginning
i mean they're the only two characters
who both refer to ford as sixer hey
what's the word sixer a deal's a deal
sixer that's a pretty weird coincidence
they both tell people to buy gold before
the impending apocalypse
buy gold you've been buying gold right
they even do that whole eeny meeny miny
you
thing eeny meeny miny you eeny
miney one way to absolve his crime
a different form a different time
hmm in the episode the inconveniencing
mabel has a hallucination where a giant
dog talks backwards he tells her to
we've already established how backwards
talk tends to relate to bill
and now we have someone speaking
backwards telling us not to trust
grunkle stan
i know he had a couple secrets within
the show but none of them were so
serious that it was cause to really
distrust him
this even puts a whole new meaning on
the cryptogram found in the title
sequence
stan is not what he seems all the
gravity falls theorists just kind of
brushed that one off as a reference to
him having this secret twin but
what if it was referring to something
else the entire time
could it really be possible that these
two characters are actually
one and the same i guess that's a theory
for another day
in the meantime remember reality isn't
real the universe is a hologram and
that's
just a theory a film theory
you